allied is directed by Robert Zemeckis
and stars Brad Pitt and Marion Cotillard
to people who fall in love behind enemy
lines they're both spies of sorts and at
first they're trying to fake that
they're in love to complete a mission
but it eventually becomes clear that
faking it isn't going to be too hard
anymore because you know they're both
pretty attractive people so they're
gonna bang but after one of them gets a
suspicious tip about the other doubt
starts to spread amongst their
relationship any time Robert Zemeckis
makes a film I'm very curious to see
what it is because he's directed a lot
of really great movies and I really
admired the way he makes films all of
his films feel very meticulously planned
every shot feels like it has a purpose
and he's also extremely good at blending
CG elements with real-world elements and
making it seamless allied has a lot of
good things going for it namely the
production design the costume design the
entire look and feel of this movie feels
like you're watching a movie that was
made in the 40s it takes place in 1942
and various years after that as the
movie progresses throughout the story
but this film feels extremely
old-fashioned in that it's slow-moving
just the way characters move around the
frame and the way they talk to each
other and the way the camera will
sometimes linger on an actor way longer
than most Hollywood movies you can
really get the sense that Robert
Zemeckis is trying to recreate that
golden era of Hollywood the 40s and
really make it feel that way sometimes
that's a detriment to this movie as well
because there's obvious influence from
the movie Casablanca here and sometimes
it becomes a hindrance because you just
keep seeing how much he's tributing that
film and other films of the era that
this film doesn't always become its own
film because it's trying to be so many
other films as well if you're excited
about the idea of an old-fashioned style
romance with two really attractive
people who are good at acting and a
great director allied will probably be
enough for you but for me personally I
was let down by the way this film was
paced there wasn't a sense of urgency to
their relationship there wasn't that
romantic intensity that I was looking
for it felt a little bland
which then bled over into the pacing of
the movie in regards to certain scenes
that just went on and on certain
sequences it felt like they could be cut
down significantly like there's a scene
where Brad Pitt is called in to
who talked to some people in secret and
he has to go into this underground room
and talk to these people now there were
about five shots of him walking down a
staircase and it was very slow moving as
it moves across the staircase and you
see down all the way to the bottom of
the floor then there's a long tracking
shot of him walking through the hallway
looking at people going like yes hello
then there's another shot of him walking
through a hallway very slowly and then
eventually we get to the room where he
sits down in front of these people and
I'm wondering why they had to have all
of those shots showing him walking
through these hallways and you guys know
me I love examining the way films are
directed I love looking at a beautiful
shot where nothing is really happening
it's just a gorgeous shot and yeah Brad
Pitt's a gorgeous guy but I don't need
to see a billion shots of him walking
when they could just have one or two and
the entire film has sequences like that
where it feels like they could just take
out a couple shots and really strengthen
the runtime with this movie and make it
feel a little bit more fast also this is
the first time in a Robert Zemeckis film
that I have really noticed an overuse of
CG in regards to blending and
compositing shots together because he's
going for an old-fashioned feel but as
usual Zemeckis enjoys employing a lot of
CG to make shots flow together
seamlessly and it becomes a little bit
of a distraction I like the old
fashioned feel of this film but
sometimes it was also a distraction all
the comparisons I kept making the
Casablanca I respect a lot of the things
that are on screen in this movie but in
the end when you boil it all down to it
the most important part of this movie
was probably capturing that romance and
making it feel real and it didn't feel
real to me I'm gonna give allied a C+
also just a quick meaningless tidbit I
noticed that the exact same actor plays
a Nazi in this film who challenges Brad
Pitt to a card game and this same guy
played one of the card playing Nazis in
Inglourious Basterds another Brad Pitt
film that's kind of crazy guys as I
promised you on Twitter I'm going to be
starting another series of hilarious
''tis very soon leading up to assassin's
creed 3 video game hilarious 'ti movies
and the first one is going to be this
weekend and that's DOA dead or alive one
of the greatest films ever made so I
can't wait to talk about that also I
want to make sure you guys
none of my promotion with audible.com is
still going on if you go to audible.com
slash Chris you can browse a library of
hundreds of thousands of audiobooks and
download them to your tablet to your
iPhone to your Samsung phone to your
computer to your mp3 player and listen
to the books on the go it's something
that has been a big benefit to me they
have all the Star Wars legacy novels on
there which is really cool for me
because I love Star Wars and I love the
Star Wars books if you go to audible.com
slash Chris you can get a free 30-day
trial and you can start that today and I
really hope you do that because a lot of
my viewers have thanked me for that
service and I appreciate that audible
continues to team up with me and I
really hope you guys do check out
audible.com slash Chris for that free
30-day trial thank you very much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
you